[Music]
the Kentucky Derby was this past weekend
I believe two of you saw it the race was
won by a thoroughbred named orb and a
good race horses always have good names
orb golden soul revolutionary these are
terrific names but I was watching some
of the lower stakes races earlier in the
day with the slower less exciting horses
I noticed their names are just not as
inspiring for example there's a horse
drunken toddler I don't know if you saw
him there's there's this horse Oh Jays
alibi there's this horse Mexican jury
duty I don't know look at this one the
rash came back there's Timothy's wee
correction
going down the stretch it's Timothy's
weak direction
he looks like he's trying so hard
there's my ex-wife's unreasonable
demands that's a tough name
there's increasingly fat death Aykroyd
there's disturbing German pornography
there's DJ Qualls chest x-rays there's
unredeemed $5.00 RadioShack gift card
and finally turkey on whole wheat with
lettuce tomato and mayo oh and I guess a
pickle but hey no chips thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]